welcome everyone uh welcome to the
fourth
ml for audio webinar in the series
today i'm happy to to welcome ray and
jeremy from the cancer team they will be
talking about ict city code and
speech-to-text decoding
so just as a quick introduction to them
raymond grossman works as an ml engineer
at cancer technologies he specializes in
speech and natural language domains
before working in kensho he studied math
at princeton and he was an avid gaggler
under the moniker to train them is my
cause
we also have jeremy here jeremy is a ml
engineer at kensho as well
he has worked on a variety of different
topics including search and speech
recognition
before working at kensho he earned a phd
in experimental particle physics at mit
and continued doing physics research as
a postdoc at the university of colorado
water welcome guys how are you doing
today
fantastic thank you yeah i'm doing well
too yeah thanks and um yeah thanks for
inviting us uh so so like omar said
we're talking to you today about pi ct
cd code and speech text decoding um
and so the two of us are ml engineers at
kensho and kensho is an ai
company that was founded into uh 2013
and then acquired by the financial firm
s p global in 2018
and um so now we're we've been working
and using s p's a huge amount of data to
help drive a lot of the ai innovation
within s p global and one of the
products that we offer is called kensho
scribe which is a speech-to-text tool
that will make transcripts of audio
files
so we have some
experience in the audio domain
so the way this talk is going to work is
that i will give you
an intro to ctc decoding and beam search
and then my colleague ray will um then
do a walk through the with the pi ctc
decode package in some examples
uh so for the first part i'll give you
an overview of some generic a generic
speech to text pipeline and then review
uh ctc encoding in speech attacks which
i believe you've heard of in a previous
lecture
and then talk about how to decode ctc
encoded output and finally go into
details a little bit of detail about
beam search which is what we're going to
focus on today
uh so first a review of a pretty
standard modular speaker text
architecture so the first thing
obviously you want to do is start with
an audio sample so something like mp3
file or wav file and probably the first
thing you'll want to do with this is
have some pre-processing stage which
gives you features for every chunk of
audio that's roughly some number of
milliseconds long
once you get those features you could
then pass the generated per time set
features through some neural net model
something like wave to vector citrinet
which gets a per time step logic matrix
back which you can then use to analyze
that you then want to analyze
um and so this logit matrix gives
typically will give you some like soft
max logic predicting
character probabilities for each time
slice so here's an example of one where
the x-axis is the
character out of a
vocabulary of about 30 something uh
characters and then there's a set of
about 50 time slices in this one that
i'm showing you right now
and the logics represent as i said
character probabilities but with some
twists uh so first typically in many of
these in this kind of architecture the
audio will be sliced into evenly spaced
chunks of time and you will be
predicting soft max logics for each of
these slices and this means that your
output length is proportional to your
audio length and not actually the text
length that you want to output and this
is a complication that actually is
driving uh
this ctc pro why you need the ctc
process that i'll talk about in a bit
um so once you have this logic matrix
you then want to pass that into some
sort of decoder or language model that
will then take this
matrix and return some actual text which
hopefully is human readable and sensible
and this is what we're going to be
talking about today so the process of
taking
this soft max logic output and producing
human readable text
um so ultimately what the decoder model
is doing is evaluating some sort of path
through your logic matrix
which i'll define here as a path being
that you choose one character per each
from for each time slice
uh so here i've just chosen some some
characters and let's say this spells out
the word decoding and you keep going
through the rest of the matrix
uh so then uh from here you could
actually define a simple logic based
score that combines the probabilities of
each character so if we take the logic
take your soft max log soft max of that
we can define a log probability or some
log score
which is just the sum of the log like
this log probabilities
and so given any path you can then
define some sort of score on it
okay so now i can get into uh ctc
encoding um and ctc if you forgotten
stands for uh connectionist temporal
classification
and like i said there are some
challenges in decoding these logics so
first of all typically you'll have many
more time steps than predicted
characters uh you need this because
people speak at different speeds so it
needs to be that the time steps need to
be small enough that you could actually
capture you know everyone's speech
reasonably accurately
um and also in actual human text you'll
often get things like duplicated
characters so for example in the word
the english word hello you have two l's
so you both have
repeated things from having many time
sets but also actually duplicated
characters
so as an example um so ultimately you
need a way to collapse repeated
characters without eliminating duplicate
actual duplicates so for example if you
have the
word hello that appears so someone spoke
hello and it appeared the way it does in
actual english with five characters
um that's easy but uh someone speaks
much slower maybe each of those
characters gets duplicated
and when you actually decode this into
text you want both of these things to
decode the same exact word since
ultimately they represent the same word
and the way this is done in ctc encoding
is you add a new character to our
alphabet that represents a break between
characters often this can be denoted as
pad or just an underscore
and so we could insert this new
character in between some of the l's in
the word hello
um
and then we could try to decode this
with a two-step process by what where we
uh first
you uh eliminate any duplicate
characters and then you could remove
this extra
underscore character to get the the word
um and so by that process you can then
take these two representations of the
word hello and collapse them down into
the actual english word
um
and so this is actually what happens
once you have some string to decode uh
but we start with this
logic matrix which gives you
probabilities in all possible
strings you can get out
so now we need to actually decode our
ctc output and there's a simple way you
can uh do this greedily um and uh which
basically just involves just you take
the arg max of the character logic at
each time step um so you just take the
most likely character at each time step
and then run this two-step process of
removing repeated characters and
removing this ctc break character
um and so this is very simple it's very
easy to code this up um however very
often it's not optimal
in many languages such as english you'll
have things like homophones so for
example you have the noun not versus the
word not meaning negation
um also very often this might misspell
things it's probably not gonna learn
a full language model that gives you
perfect english every time
and also many languages you have
plethora a plethora of other small
errors so for example some misspellings
could happen because you have things
like letter f or the two letters ph or
gh can all give you the same sound
and i'm sure this exists in other
languages as well so then we could ask
what happens if we have a model that
hears the word for but instead decides
the best output is uh p-h-o-r rather
than f-o-r where that might seem like uh
it gives you the correct audio but it's
not an actual word
um
so if you're an ml engineer data
scientist maybe the first thing you
think of is that you just want to
retrain your model so you try to collect
more data retrain all your models and
hope that fixes it uh the problem with
that is that
it can be very very time consuming and
very expensive to collect data and
retrain your model and even then it's
not guaranteed to actually to actually
work so you might do all this process
and find that you still have many of
these errors
so then you need to think of what else
can you do
um so there's two things you want to
consider here first we know a lot of
information about human language can we
actually inject information about
language into our decoding to try to
guide it to give us more natural
sounding output
and also uh is there a way we can try to
use maybe a slightly better decoding
strategy than this greedy
solution
so first i'll talk about uh language
models and how we can inject language
information into our output
uh so ultimately uh you know because
these problems we we need to uh try to
see if can we score how likely a given
block of text is to appear in natural
language given the fact that we have
these logics that represent the audio
that we heard but we also potentially
have a lot of natural text we could use
to build a language model that we could
then try to use to remove improbable
parts of the predicted text so if the
most probable thing is actually it
doesn't look very much like natural
language we could then maybe down wait
that and upweight something that looks
more natural
also a very common way to do this is
with an engram language model which is
more of a traditional kind of language
model that existed before deep learning
became
very popular but there's other language
models you could use
but if you use an n-gram model basically
it's a probabilistic model where given
some sequence of words of size n minus
one we want to predict what the nth word
is
and so this can be used to identify
improbable shorter sequences of text
that maybe would need to be changed
and again we use it in conjunction with
our
logics or
audio probabilities so so that um we can
try to weight everything by
what the logic the language model says
and so for the purposes here basically a
language model is going to be something
that we can take some proposed text and
output some sort of likelihood or some
sort of score
uh so for example if you
show the english phrase the angry brown
cat that sounds pretty close to like
natural english so maybe that's going to
give it get a pretty high likelihood or
pretty high score let's say we just have
some language model that outputs a score
of 0.4 or something
but then we can also enter some text
like the angry cat brown uh which
is sounds less natural zach probably
gets a lower score it's not zero since
maybe you know brown is the name of the
cat so it's something that could appear
in some language just with probably a
much lower probability than the previous
text
so just a way to take any text and try
to score it
and so for in a generic language model
maybe you can say the problem you can
decompose this problem saying the
probability of some sequence of text is
going to be the probability of each word
given all the previous text that you saw
um
and then what makes the n-gram model an
n-gram model is that we limit ourselves
so instead of taking all the previous
text we only take the previous n minus
one words um and we do this for each of
the each of the words to get a
probability on the whole text
um and so one of the reasons why you
want to do this uh is that
generally you need to train these
language models off some large test
corpus
but if you have too many
words that you you include you just
don't have any examples so you just
can't set a good probability so you need
to limit yourselves on only a small
number of words that way you can try to
build a decent
model with good probabilities on each of
these
each of these sequences
uh so for example a bi-gram language
model which is n equals two
uh we could say we could give it say the
opening line of uh dickens the tail of
two cities which is it was the best of
times and let's say we add in a start
and end character to our text to say
this is the beginning this is the end of
it then in a bygram model the
probability of getting our text our text
would be something like the probability
of getting the end of the sequence uh
given that the previous word was the
word times times the probability of
getting times given the previous word
was of and so on so in the the by
grammar n equals 2 n gram model
basically your model just has to
memorize probabilities of these pairs of
words
so you know it just has to memorize a
pair of words and not any long strings
so hopefully you get your pretty good
probabilities from like a decent sized
text set but typically you can go more
than this you can do three or four maybe
even up to five or so um
for n but probably not much beyond that
before you start just not getting enough
examples to get good probabilities
and then we can try to incorporate this
language model with our logits as we
decode them up as we decode them so when
scoring a path with logics really what
you're trying to do is assign a score to
any given output text you can then
get the raw score of the output text
given your output logics and then add in
some extra score
given your language model
and so the idea here is that if you have
a very highly weighted um
piece of text
you will have a very
you know pretty high
score so you'll have a very small
penalty here but if you have a very
poorly weighted text so the text looks
very unnatural it will get a larger
penalty and be down weighted
and so this way you can include language
model information into your decoding of
your audio
and then another thing we can do besides
adding language models is that we can
try to see if there are better
algorithms to use
so for example given a language model
that we have if we want one how can we
decode our logics in a better way
uh so there is a true solution here
which is more accurate than the greedy
solution and that is you can score every
possible path your logic matrix
um including any language model
information if you want to include that
and then you want to combine the scores
of all your equivalent paths to get a
total score for some text and then take
the highest scoring piece of text
um so this gives you an exact solution
more or less an exact solution but the
problem here is that this is exponential
complexity
so even if you say have 32 output
characters
and
say just 10
output time steps which potentially is
not even a single word
even with that case you already have
something like 10 to the 15 paths to go
through
uh which means that this is just
impossible to actually do you just don't
have the time or the memory to
go through every single path in any
realistic solution
um and also it turns out probably in
most cases the vast majority of these
paths will have a very very tiny
probability
so what we need is actually an
intermediate solution so something that
maybe is more complicated than just
taking the arg max at each time step but
also is
you know going to be less disastrously
slow is actually trying to go and take
every possible path
and this brings us to beam search
which is an example of one of these and
what uh we use in our package um that
we'll talk about later
and so beam search gives us a fast
approximate solution to this and the
idea is that we'll take the n best
characters from our first time slice so
we start the first time slice take the
best characters and so we this we call
this we have n beams that we want to
start with
so let's say we start with the letters f
and p for our first times time step
and then we go to the next time step and
try to add a second character to each of
our initial
beams
then we score these
and then we prove the number of
sequences that we keep down to our
desired beam with which is this um this
number n so here let's say we have n
equals 2 so then the next time step we
go and have
um you continue with two beams then we
try to add a third character
um score them prune back down to n
equals two here and so on until we've
gone through our each of our time steps
and so basically what we're doing is
we're iteratively
building paths through our logic matrix
but just keeping the highest weighted
ones at each at each step
and so if you think about this a bit you
can see that this actually ends up
essentially interpolating between the
two extremes that i mentioned so in a
beam width of one we just keep the
highest weighted
uh character at each step which is
essentially identical to this greedy
decoding although maybe including a
language model if we want to add one and
anything any other bells and whistles
that we that you might want to add to
your decoding um then at a beam width of
infinity where you include all possible
paths you hopefully end up with an exact
solution
so this is a way you know you can then
optimize by choosing your beam width to
try to give you good um results while
also
being fast enough to actually be
effective for however you want to use
your your speech to text system
and then once we have this um like i
said you have to score your beams at
each position um so a little bit about
that so as i said you're building paths
through your
logic matrix and and so
i already mentioned to score a path you
just take can take you know the sum of
log soft maxes of your of your logits as
before also this is what you saw before
um and then um potentially you get
multiple paths that give you the same
output so you want to actually sum your
probabilities over equivalent beams uh
so you want to go over your beams and
here's a um the eye
here is is an uh indicator
function where you just choose any
uh beams that give you the exact same
output or the beams that are essentially
equivalent and add together
the uh the probabilities there
and that gives you the probability of
your of given getting some output text
okay so that's what i wanted to talk
about uh today for just the
theory of of how to do this ctc decoding
so as i said uh the ctc encoding is a
pretty common way for audio models to
output character information this is
especially relevant in the case of
modular systems um it's not that's not
the only architecture that's possible
and then the pi cdcd code package that
you'll hear about next is a package that
was developed to decode ctc encoded
logits
with language model if you want to use
it and also using a beam search to try
to find the best text
uh and so now i can uh pass this over to
our ray to talk about pi cdcd code
awesome thank you jeremy
um
so pi ctcd code is again a python
package i've included links to
both the package and the code that will
be used later in this presentation to
generate some samples we're going to
look at this should also all be
available as information on the talk git
so what is pi ctcd code basically it is
a package we developed at kensho that
decodes cdc encoded logits
it is python which means it's simple
code and it's both easy to extend with
new features and hopefully easy to use
and common ml workflows
i don't want to talk too much about you
know the benefits of pi ct cd code it
feels a little suspicious so let's move
on to the features
basically everything that jeremy
discussed in part one is implemented in
pi ctcd code
we offer beam search to determine
you know quasi-optimal output text given
a logic matrix we all also offer
language model support uh using canalem
currently as our backend package for the
language model
and of course if you want to do greedy
decoding you can do that with no
language model just by setting a beam
width at 1.
and we also offer some additional
features that are useful
the first one of those additional
features is hot word boosting basically
you can pass a list of hot words to your
decoder and boost the probabilities for
each one in a given
audio clip that you're
predicting on
this is extremely useful in a lot of
common speech text scenarios
one example is early in 2020 when
coronavirus and kovid became extremely
commonplace phrases in our language but
there wasn't a lot of training data that
included those terms you could adjust
your acoustic models to
often predict these simply by using
coronavirus or covet as a hot word and
boosting the probability of them
appearing in the language model
basically the way this is implemented is
very very similar to an existing
language model it just adds an
additional penalty or score based on the
hot words that you pass to our existing
probability for any given beam
we also offer a lot of benefits just in
terms of it being available in python
and still having uh comparable speed
um so the c plus package we previously
used wasn't any faster than our package
and we achieved this by using
extensive beam pruning and also very
efficient caching
we reject beams with particular
probabilities and we also aggressively
cache partial results during calculation
so we don't have to keep passing similar
strings to the language model
um i don't want to throw any shade on
the the package that we were using
previously so it's just marked as other
uh but you can see that we have
comparable speed without sacrificing and
even improving word arrow rate over the
package we're using previously
um and there's a lot of other features
we want to add to pi ctcd code one thing
that we have on the docket is
potentially adding uh some transformer
based or neural language models
of course these this brings its own set
of challenges it's an additional high
complexity model to maintain any
production pipeline it also has high run
time
but if you have anything that you think
would be useful feel free to submit a
feature request to the github
with the
the background on pi cdc code out of the
way let's get started with the actual
package uh so what do we need to get
started
well
probably the package for starters but
jokes aside
to use pictures decode effectively you
really need four things
and the first thing that you need is a
text corpus to train
the
language model on and ideally it would
be the same text corpus that you use to
train your acoustic model
you also need an acoustic model
pi cc cd code can handle either byte
pairing coded or character based models
and i think if you're looking for an
acoustic model to get started hugging
face has all of your needs covered there
if you are using the existing
model you also need the vocab set for
the above model and you need to make
sure that your language model is trained
on the same
vocabulary set the text that is used has
the same vocabulary set
and the final thing that you need is the
language model itself we currently offer
support for only kennel m which
implements the engram model on the back
end
so for this talk and if you're looking
for a data set to get started we use
spgi speech
this is again a bit of self-promotion
but this data set is pretty awesome and
if you haven't looked into it you
definitely should it's uh about 5 000
hours of financial audio and associated
transcripts for reference that's about
5x the size of librespeech which is you
know the main speech to text datasets
that's been used in research for the
past decade
and it's basically consisted of company
earnings calls that are split into short
chunks which allows for easy speech
recognition training
it uh it contains over 50 000 unique
speakers with a variety of accents and
speaking conditions which makes it very
comprehensive
and
the entire train and vowel set are the
result of manual transcription which
means it's very well normalized it has a
very polished orthograph orthography and
in general it's it's a very very strong
data set um i promise that any model you
train using a 5x larger data set will
probably perform better
then you can once you have a data set
you can pull in an acoustic model
bpe or character based the only thing
that you need here is a vocabulary set
associated with the model that you're
using
and then you need to normalize the text
corpus
for your language model so that it uses
the same vocabulary as your acoustic
model
i've included an example snippet here
this is using
the hugging face
wave to vec base model
this both pulls in the model and gets
you the vocabulary set
and then finally you need a kenlam model
klm is another python package and
instructions for how to train the kennel
model with spg speech are available in
the demo repo
again
and i can't stress this enough making
sure your vocabulary sets match is
absolutely critical if there's even a
slight mismatch it can lead to really
really strange behavior in the way these
models perform one example is
the hyphen character
if it's not included in one of the
vocabulary sets
what will happen is is words that should
be
hyphenated or if they're not hyphenated
probably delineated with a space
end up mashed together which can cause
some problems with the language model
output
cool so once you have all these pieces
you can get started by making a decoder
it's a simple call to build ctc decoder
and you
only have to pass the vocab in your
kennel model
then once you have your decoder you can
decode a logic matrix simply by using a
call to dot code
cool so let's let's move on to some
examples i tried to pick a
a wide spread of examples for this
presentation from those where the
language model helps a lot to those
where it doesn't and hopefully the idea
behind this presentation is that
you'll sort of get a good idea for how
language models tend to work in practice
the sorts of errors that they fix and
the sorts of areas that they don't fix
and also what you can do to tune them
and make them as effective as possible
when you are using language models
yourself
again all the code is available in the
in the demo repo if you're curious it's
very approachable it's not a lot of code
and should be easy to get off the ground
so let's start with some examples
the first example we have is one where
the language model performs pretty well
and here is the audio clip we are going
to be predicting on
i also want to remind everyone that any
forward-looking statements made during
this call are subject to risks and
uncertainties the most important of
which are described in our press release
and sec filings
and let's listen to that one more time
i also want to remind everyone that any
forward-looking statements made during
this call are subject to risks and
uncertainties the most important of
which are described in our press release
and sec filings
so this sample is pretty straightforward
it seems like most acoustic models
should be able to predict pretty well on
it
there's not a lot of background noise
the speaker is fairly clear there's a
little bit of static but not too much
so we have the ground truth which is i
also want to remind everyone
so on and so forth
and then we pass it through the acoustic
model and
use a greedy decoding to get back a
predicted block of text we get something
that is indeed quite accurate
um it's almost identical to the
predicted text uh of course our the
model that i use for this demo doesn't
include punctuation or capitalization so
neither neither of those are present but
the only two real errors it has are at
the end of the text it says press
release instead of press release and it
says scc instead of sec filings
so we can address these sorts of areas
easily with our language model if we
pass a language model that
you know has seen a lot of financial
text it's seen both the phrase press
release and sec filings many many many
times and so it's able to correct both
of these issues with our acoustic model
very easily
but there are also cases where the
language model doesn't perform as well
so let's look at a second sample
thank you ivan i'm now going to look in
a bit more detail at what is as ivan
said a good set of results with better
top line performance margin expansion
and increased cash flow
let's listen to that one more time
thank you ivan i'm now going to look in
a bit more detail at what is as ivan
said a good set of results with better
top line performance margin expansion
and increased cash flow
again this is a pretty clear sample i
think that for the most part it's going
to be
something that an acoustic model should
perform quite well on and an
appropriately trained language model
should also be able to perform quite
well on
this is the ground truth
and if we pass it through and get a
greedy decoding we can see that the
greedy coding is actually
excuse me is actually quite strong
it's almost entirely correct we have
um
only one error in this and it's
something that would would ding your
word error rate score but it's not
actually a huge error from a human
perspective at the end of the sequence
we have
the words cache and flow merged into a
single word
not the end of the world
but if we pass this through a language
model then we actually run into some
problems so
instead of the opening phrase thank you
ivan it now returns thank you even
probably because even is a more
probabilistically likely word in any
given sentence after thank you than ivan
is and this is this is an issue
um
we'd like to minimize these sorts of
areas as much as possible and this is
also the sort of area that a human might
look at and think is
not that great because thank you even
doesn't make any sense as language
despite coming out of the language model
it's interesting to note that in this
sample we would actually get a better wr
score word error rate score
from the language model decoding than we
would from the original sequence even
though
the transcription is objectively worse
or maybe subjectively worse as a human
i'm not sure
because it fixes the error with cache
and flow at the end so that is two words
that were incorrect which are now
correct and it only makes a single
mistake on the first ivan
but still this is this is the sort of
thing that we would not want
uh it's worth noting that despite these
types of areas language models are still
quite useful
um
on our internal valve side at kensho we
we get about a six percent improvement
in our word error rate simply from
adding a language model and this is this
is with a very large acoustic model that
we trained on almost 100 000 hours of of
audio
uh so that's a pretty strong endorsement
that
you know language models and engram
language models are very useful in
almost any speech to text scenario
uh but that doesn't really change the
fact that it still introduces some of
these errors um and especially in this
case what seems like a
somewhat bad error
in changing a phrase from
readable english to something that
doesn't really make sense so how can we
address these errors well
uh the easiest way are through some of
the features and the package
uh the first thing we can do is we can
boost hot words for things that may be
specific to our prediction domain so for
example if if we're transcribing some
sort of call uh maybe maybe a hangout or
a
um
you know any any sort of earnings call
where we know the names of the people on
the call we could
boost those names
or you know again
words like cova that may be common but
not on our training corpus we can boost
things like that
the second option that we have is we can
try and adjust the parameters to
increase or decrease the weight on the
language model
and we can try and get a solution that
seems more appropriate
for the for the actual prediction corpus
that we're using
let's uh let's look at the first
solution and try hot word boosting on
our previous sample
um
so for this
the
uh
the ability to add hot words is very
simple we just create a list of words we
want to pass
it can be any list of words and then we
pass those through to the decoder
and
we add some sort of weight for these hot
words for this example i've added a
fairly high weight
you probably want to be more subtle than
that if you were
actually adding hot words in practice
but if we pass the same sample um
through a language model that includes
hot words uh what actually happens is we
take our
our error thank you evan and it
fixes it back to thank you ivan
and this is pretty ideal
i think this is obviously
something that's very useful in many
common transcription scenarios
you can use it in anything from a call
with no speaker names uh to adjusting
your models to new corporate um but
again this is something that can easily
be abused uh if you overweight words too
extensively it can lead to some very
very strange outputs where the the
language model will almost overwrite
words that it probably shouldn't
uh so always worth both validating and
having a visual check on these sorts of
things
uh and then that brings us to our our
second method of improving language
models which is parameter tuning
and pi ctcd code offers two
tunable params
the first is alpha and basically that's
just the weight on the language model
versus the logits during
the fusion of the two
and beta is
a
constant factor that is
the weight for the length score
adjustment it's sort of hard to wrap
your head around what
beta is doing
but it just makes the language model
more likely to add or remove words in
practice
um
and
keep in mind when doing any sort of
parameter tuning on modeling pipelines
that have more than one step you need to
be very very careful with your
validation
if you tune these sorts of parameters on
your validation set
then you
validate on that same validation set
you'll get inflated wr scores from what
you would expect on a new and unseen
test set because you've basically leaked
information to the language model
and
this means that you should always always
avoid tuning on your validation set
these sorts of parameters
a better way to set up a pipeline like
this is to split your training set into
a vast majority of it should go into the
data set used to train your acoustic
model and your language model and then
you should keep a very small
holdout to tune the parameters on your
language model after your acoustic model
and language model have been trained and
then you should have your validation set
be completely separate from this entire
operation
and it's also really important to have a
visual check on these sorts of changes
while you're tuning
if the parameters are too high
you can still get a good wr as we saw in
our example with ivan it fixed cash flow
and improved the wr but led to a sample
that looked really really bad from a
human perspective um and this sort of
leads to a fairly high
embarrassment score
or i don't know that's not a real metric
but
uh
it basically leads to predictions where
a human is going to look at it and
wonder exactly what happened to lead to
that which is never what you want in
transcription
but concerns with validation aside let's
move on to an example and see how
parameter tuning can be deployed in
practice
and here is the audio sample
whereas then
in the industrial cranes and green
components business units
and i'm going to play that a couple more
times
whereas then
in the industrial cranes and crane
components business units
whereas then
in the industrial cranes and crane
components business units
and this is a worse quality audio sample
than previous two it's a little hard to
hear if your volume isn't turned
entirely up
and it also is
uh
less clear in terms of the the accent in
the speech
and you'll note that the ground truth
that is used in our data set actually
omits
the uh
the uh sound
he says whereas then uh in the
industrial cranes
and so on but the the transcription
eliminates that and this leads to some
problems when we're passing it through
the acoustic model
the model doesn't really know
what to do with that situation and so we
end up with a transcription that is
pretty bad
we get where he has t-e-i-n-a in the
industrial grains and crane spelled
incorrectly components business units
and if we pass this to some sort of wr
evaluation
it would score pretty poorly maybe
around the 50 mark
um
simply because there are so many words
that are either slightly off or or just
plain and cracked
um
and obviously
this is the sort of thing that we would
expect a language model to do
uh an okay job of fixing and indeed if
we pass it to a language model with sort
of default parameters it performs pretty
well
it comes back with more readable english
instead of
this sort of nonsensical start we have
it correctly identifies where he has
than in the industrial
unfortunately it doesn't fix the latter
part of the sentence we still have
grains and grain components despite the
fact that industrial grains and grain
components
probably is a very unlikely or
unrealistic phrase in the english
english language
so how can we address this well if we
turn up the the
input that our language model has
uh you know alpha updates language model
and beta increases its its ability um to
add or remove words
then we end up with something that is
that is even better we get something
where the first grain is actually fixed
to cranes uh and although it doesn't fix
the second grain it's still an
improvement
um and you can actually
continue tuning this and get to a point
where
it fixes both cranes and the second
crane correctly but if you turn it up
too high it starts to degrade
performance in other areas so it's a bit
of a balancing act here
so
these can clearly have a significant
impact
but again
be very very careful when tuning stuff
like this if you have leakage on
validation you're going to have a really
bad time and also
um you know
anytime you're doing
language like this it's important to do
some visual checking of the results at
the end
and that is all that we had for you
today
i hope that
some of you are able to use pctc code in
your own
speech to text
adventures and
with that
are there any questions comments
concerns
i guess we can uh we can open it up
awesome yeah thanks a lot uh that was a
great presentation let me switch screens
yeah so just as a reminder for people
that join later
if you're in youtube you can scroll down
a bit and there's a link to default
there you can ask any questions that you
might have
later on we'll
go over each of these questions we'll go
over them now but we'll also add some
resources and pointers to the specific
point in the video because this will be
recorded
so yeah feel free to ask any questions
and additionally you can also find the
github repository
of the hooking phase ml for audio study
group here you can see
the demo the slides the link to the
questions and additional resources for
this topic
having said that thanks again for the
great presentation and maybe let's jump
directly
to the questions
so the first question is i was wondering
how the hot word boosting is implemented
is it simply changing the probabilities
of the language model by a factor of x
or is it something fancy
yeah so i think it is it is not that
fancy so it's actually implemented after
the language model so
the text is passed to the language model
and we have our score from the logit
matrix and it's added as an additional
term onto the formula that calculates
the beam score so we have our language
model score
our logit score and then our hot word
score
and they're all
separate awesome thanks
yeah next question from bb is what is
the future road map for basicity code
um i can
take that um i think
right now there's not really a clear
exact road map um so so there's been
some changes to try to add support for
some hugging face um
uh code more recently uh but i i think
really it's just um
figure out if the community wants a
specific addition or
or something we can we can think about
adding that so so if we want more
integrations with different packages and
things
that would be something that we would
certainly consider
but i think there's not necessarily a
exact roadmap right now so it really is
up to the people who want to use the
package to request things
yeah and i think there are a few things
that we are going to try internally uh
we're definitely going to try you know
transformer based language models uh
and
i think uh
over the next couple of months hopefully
have some updates there but i think that
i agree with jeremy the vast majority of
things are going to be up to the
feature requests from the community
a final member from the community and i
would like to request new features or
discuss uh
what the right place to go would be to
create an issue in your github
repository
absolutely yes
all right let's go to the next question
i think these are actually three
different questions so maybe let's go
one by one
and the first one is how many hot words
can we add to the language model
yeah so i don't think there's there's
any sort of limit here but i think that
um this is something that needs to be
tuned if you add too many hot words
it'll start to degrade the performance
of the language model i think that you
really want to use hot words in very
targeted scenarios and you should try
and limit them as much as possible
if you find yourself adding you know
an enormous list of hot words it might
be time to look at either retraining
your language model or retraining your
acoustic model
and uh
may i go to the second question
yeah so the build for everything does
not take very long uh so if you wanted
to run all of the code in the demo repo
including building the cantaloupe model
uh it would only take maybe maybe 10 or
15 minutes with the vast majority of
that being setting up things on your own
end
so you know changing the path to your
own data set path identifying
the vocab for the model you want to use
things like that
okay great and the third question is can
basically code
handle foreign languages such as korean
yeah i think
this is a difficult one
so
i'm not going to pretend that i have
extensive experience in doing speech
texts in languages that aren't alphabet
based
it seems like
pi ctcd code should be able to handle
any
foreign language that uses an alphabet
and it seems like
as long as your language model is
language appropriate
then
it might be able to handle something
like korean but we haven't tested it
um i don't know jeremy do you have any
um
yeah i've never tested that i believe
korean is mostly alphabet based just a
different character set
um and it's slightly but i don't know i
don't want to say that i know it's
specific so because i don't really know
much about the korean language yeah so i
think as long as you have something that
is alphabet or similar
um
i would expect it to work if there's
something like chinese where you have
thousands of characters which aren't
necessarily phonetic i
wouldn't be surprised if it doesn't work
that well but i don't know um maybe
there's some extra processes you need to
add for that kind of case
but yeah that's something i'm not sure
that would be a great direction to put
on the
the reprojection
okay
thanks er
i think this one is not a specific
question it's just that
this person is interested in the
specifics of the implementation and what
is the mask behind it
as i mentioned before the presentation
is recorded the slides are also
available and there's also code as well
as
the repository and additional resources
so yeah i believe this question
all right so this one is in for a
specific issue
so
the issue is difficulty seeing
meaningful changes with hardcore
boosting
a user is having issues where he's not
seeing meaningful differences when using
hot wars even if avoiding the words to a
very large number like
yeah nine million nine nine twenty yeah
i tried this myself and i had the same
experience can you please elaborate on
this issue and if you have made any
attempts to make it easier for users to
fine-tune their language models
uh sure i could handle a bit on how this
could happen i don't specif the
specifics in that
issues i think that was from quite a
while ago um
uh but there's a few ways that this
could happen so first of all as you're
building beams in beam search to even
get to
upgrading a hot word the b needs to
actually include that hot word um and so
potentially if that word is
um too low weighted uh and just never
build that beam or you've pruned it it's
pruned it away since there are some
other parameters we didn't talk about
involving you know pruning away anything
that's below some probability threshold
um
uh then potentially that beam just never
got built and and so even though the hot
word is there you never actually
found it um and so that's something that
could be addressed by potentially
you know changing the threshold some of
the pruning thresholds or increasing the
number of beams will try to expose more
results that maybe will get you to that
but i think if you're doing this sort of
approximate solution this is just always
probably going to be the chance that you
just
don't see that solution
awesome thanks
er
all right so we have again a couple of
questions uh let me know if you think
the scope for this first one might be a
bit
too big yeah
so they are asking please explain
different approaches like p3
wsft and bim search
what are the differences especially in
terms of accuracy and efficiency
yeah i don't know if we have you know
enough time to really get into this in
depth yeah maybe we could we could add
some resources to alternative
um
yeah i mean i can face github
yeah and like i think
if i remember correctly i think viterbi
is basically something like the exact
solutions you you you're trying to
dynamic programming build up every
possible solution or at least try to
find the top ones which
uh i don't know i don't want to promise
that i know the exact answer but i think
that's more like the less efficient but
more accurate solution
um and then
uh
wsft i'm not sure that was that w
is that misspelled for finite state
transformers or or transducers or yeah
i'm not sure
or
uh but that might be related to like the
implementation of a language model but
yeah i think that's something we should
take offline or off like the call
sure sure makes sense thanks
and then they are asking how to choose
the beam size for the beam search
yeah i think that um in practice it's
really just a trade-off between
performance and
and
um speed
so the performance tends to level off
pretty strongly
so if if you go back to the slide where
we had the graph of performance and
wr the performance tends to strongly
level off once you get you know
up to beamwidths of about you know
30 to 50 and you can keep going higher
than that with very marginal
improvements
but
i think that the way i would choose it
in practice
is to try and choose the fastest beam
size that gave
like you know within a an epsilon of the
performance that you're looking for
um
i think a good starting point is
probably around 20.
right yeah this kind of a follow-up
question is
is the beam size related to the acoustic
model
is it true that some others need a
larger beam size for generating
reasonable text sequences
um yeah this can be this can be a little
bit true especially when you get into
the differences between uh vocabulary
based and by parent
encoded based models i think that with
biparent coded models you'll find that
you need a slightly larger beam size to
get
the performance increases that you want
but in general
like i don't think it's that significant
of a difference it's really hard to put
exact numbers on this uh on the spot but
right thanks
and final question from mariamaz is how
to choose the number of support pieces
in bpa for the coding
so i'm not sure exactly what this this
question is trying to ask
so
your by parent coding uh your word
pieces in the byte pairing coding should
be
generated prior to training your
acoustic model and they should be set in
your vocab and the decoder
the language model doesn't actually know
anything about bite-pairing coding if
you have a byte-pairing-coded vocabulary
it generates a score for
previous words in the same way it would
for a character-based model and then
when it has a new complete word to add
then it rescores the the language
um
so
the the number
of sub word pieces in your byte pairing
coding shouldn't really have an impact
on the way pi cd code functions
although yeah i would suspect if you
have like a really really huge number of
them potentially there will be some
slowdown i would imagine but
but yeah i i haven't
thought about how it meant at what point
that happens
right thanks uh
yeah so this question from iska is
during the training of our sdt system at
say wave 2.2 do we include the language
model
so we do city coding with an lm during
training
yeah so i think that um
this is an interesting question so you
can use it as an evaluation
so obviously periodically you want to do
some evaluation during training to see
how your model is doing
you could include a language model there
but i think you're probably just as well
off doing some sort of greedy decoding
they are very very correlated
and i think the increase in complexity
and runtime from having a language model
called during your training loop is not
going to be worth potentially the the
slight increase in accuracy
right thanks
er all right so we have two last
questions for today uh so the first one
is
can we use it
for rnn based and attention based models
to generate text to
i'm actually not sure i understand this
question
i think anything that you know has a
character-based logic matrix as an
output
should be
should be
you know amenable to
using language model decoder on but to
be honest i've never really tried
so
um
i've never tried with rnn it should work
for something like uh transducer though
all right thanks and last question is is
it possible to use acoustic models
with phoneme output with specificity
code and add a lexicon
i have no idea jeremy
um
so i think certainly i think without a
language model probably it would be
fine since that's just a different
character set we have phonemes and but
then to get actual text uh uh i would
imagine the language model would have to
work differently we'd have to somehow
be able to analyze you know take a set
of phonemes and produce words so
maybe with a different kind of language
model you can you can include that as
well first but i think if you all you
want to do is you know output
you know
beam search through phonemes and output
phonemes that i think that would work um
but yeah i think that would probably
require some this would require some
extra i think implementation of features
probably
all right all right i think that's
everything for today just as a reminder
for people watching
you can find the demo the slides the
questions additional resources as well
in the github repository it's linked
right in the video and this video is
recorded if it will be in the youtube
channel by tomorrow
and please join me in thanking jeremy
and ray
in the chat and feel free to join the
discord server as well
we are having meetings every one or two
weeks we also have paper discussions for
example
uh this thursday we have a discussion
uh on wave 2 back to uh so please feel
free to join and yeah ray jeremy thanks
a lot for the presentation it was great
thank you omar appreciate you uh taking
the time to set this up
great thank you
thanks see you everyone